[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ed werder has more
espn nfl reporter he covers the cowboys
but he can speak on a variety of topics
there with
the nfl in fact ed let me start with you
more interested in finding out about
aaron rodgers or deshawn watson's
immediate future
i think i'm more interested in finding
out about desean watson just because
there are more compelling factors
involved in terms of
you know a player of his stature being
sued uh you know being investigated by
police being investigated by the nfl
we know the nfl is not going to move in
and put
aaron rodgers on the commissioner's
exempt list this is something for the
packers and the player to work out
uh there are more elements involved in
the desean watson decision
which occurs about a week from today
we'll see whether he reports and he's on
the field and the nfl allows
and then i'm i i don't know if we've had
breaking news with aaron rodgers
what shafty reported yesterday to me
wasn't breaking news because
we had heard about this for the last
couple of months there
i can't imagine a guy coming off an mvp
season
one of the greats of all time and we
still don't know what he wants
like i just find that a great mystery
and nobody's been able to put
any of these comments into context here
ed
well there's been a lot of speculation
about what his endgame is
and some of it is that he wants you know
the general manager replaced he
certainly
placed uh gutenhurst under a lot of
scrutiny here
um and if the general manager were
threatened by the possibility of getting
fired because of rogers it seems like he
would have already moved rogers by now
to me i think just observing what aaron
has
said over the past few weeks when he's
been in public situations at a couple
different golf tournaments
i get the sense that he knows he can't
win right now
he'll take the best outcome he can get
and i think he'll play for the packers
this year eventually
all right you're covering the cowboys
cowboys open up camp today the steelers
open up camp they'll meet in the hall of
fame game
uh it seems like everything is good in
dallas with cowboys is that
correct everything is good at the moment
uh obviously the man who manages the
expectations so well
here in dallas jerry jones uh will speak
to us in a couple of hours
really in person for the first time
uh for more than a year and with the
hard knock cameras rolling i have great
expectations for
for what the man might say to us today
you know he used to drive troy aikman
absolutely crazy this time of year
because
uh back in the 90s he would always
predict a super bowl and so
anything short of that was a failure
which just drove the players
insane uh he's avoided saying such
things recently
but i think expectations are and should
be pretty high
given what we've seen from dak prescott
recovering from lael collins tyron smith
i mean it all comes down to injuries but
they play in a bad division
um i i think it's a you know mike
mccarthy i think is under some pressure
this year
uh it's been a long time since he's won
the team he left has
done nicely without him the team he's
come to has fared not so well although
there certainly were some extenuating
circumstances his first year in dallas
last year
yeah i'm trying to figure all of this
out that uh you know i'm sure
the reports will be ezekiel elliott's in
the best shape of his career and
like it's always the verbal bouquets are
being thrown out
when it comes to the cowboys because i
think the media
either consciously or subconsciously
wants the cowboys to do well
like when they or at least have some
kind of storyline there
did jerry jones make the decision that
he wanted
hard knocks uh according to what the way
the cowboys have characterized it they
were asked to do it
um you know and and jerry doesn't really
have any
uh he's not revolted by the idea of his
brand
being out there and being at the
forefront in the nfl he thinks it helps
the entire league if the cowboys
uh are capturing a lot of media
attention um
so i i don't know that they solicited it
um but i think that i don't think they
mind having that opportunity especially
you know given like i said they have a
very out front
owner and general manager and jerry
jones uh he likes to promote his brand
he likes the opportunity to speak
to the public himself and so uh this
arrangement will allow all of that to
happen now
there have been times i think when
coaches have been exposed
uh you know in front of the cameras
given how intrusive they are we're gonna
get a real sense of how
mike mccarthy runs his cowboys football
team and and maybe that'll be good and
maybe it won't be
it hasn't been good for everybody now
if you're going to ask one question to
jerry jones
what's edward are going to ask today
uh wow that's a good question dan i
haven't given that enough thought if i
could ask one question to mike mccarthy
i'd ask him about his experience with
aaron rodgers and his experience with
the packers and how he thinks that whole
thing plays out
uh i like that but but dallas fans would
probably not be as uh interested in that
and it might be the last time mccarthy
takes a question from me um
but i guess i guess i would ask you know
jerry what
uh how he feels like he managed the dac
negotiations and
what disadvantages they now have to
overcome because of what they wound up
having to pay him
you know probably two years late they
you know i think they created a bad
situation for themselves when
two years ago they did what they said
they wouldn't and they honored ezekiel
elliott with the highest paid
running back contract and all the
football at a time where the running
back position has really been devalued
including here in dallas by the coach he
hired
i mean to me that's sort of a misfit
situation i know zeke's in great shape i
think
you know he's a terrific football player
and among the best running backs in the
league but that's not the way mike
mccarthy plays football
i mean last year when they started
together mccarthy in 13 years in green
bay never had a running back finished in
the top 10
in attempts zeke elliott had more
carries than anybody in football
uh since he was drafted in 2016. so i
think zeke elliott is done
uh challenging for rushing championships
and maybe that's fine i think he'd still
be a huge part of a winning team
if the right circumstances are created
for him to dominate the closeout games
and
so forth like derek henry does in in
tennessee but
but i just i don't think it makes sense
a year later to hire mike mccarthy a guy
who has very little regard for the
running game
when he paid ezekiel elliott to be the
highest paid running back in football he
you know spent all this money and draft
collateral on arranging a great
offensive line
that's dominant up front under jason
garrett yeah i'm still not sure the
philosophy here it comes down to defense
i
i've said this all along the last well
whenever
it comes down to if you win a
championship it comes down to somebody
making a defensive play
and whether it's malcolm butler or chris
jones with the uh the chi like it's a
small thing and you go
oh i got all these stars all these
offensive weapons everybody's putting up
these great fantasy numbers it comes
down to can you stop somebody at some
point in the season
can dallas stop somebody well they
couldn't stop anybody last year
uh they gave up a franchise record 473
points but you know then
you know dan they've only played
football in dallas for 61 years so
the small sample size they allowed
two of the three single highest rushing
totals in an individual game
in franchise history they allowed 27
touchdown passes to wide receivers the
most in the nfl last year so they were
horrible across the board
and that's why mike nolan got fired
after one season of the defensive
coordinator
but that was a that's a mike mccarthy
hire so
beyond all the bad decisions and there
were bad hires
and i think dan quinn uh is going to be
a much
take a much more aggressive approach on
defense obviously they dedicated their
draft to defense in a way they never
have before their first six players were
all defensive players
so i think that gives them a chance but
i overall dan to your point
i think the cowboys see themselves were
trying to achieve being the kansas city
chiefs
they want to be a great offensive team
puts up a lot of points makes a lot of
explosive plays
and then just be good on defense um and
maybe they can
achieve i think i know they can achieve
the first part i think they could be
really good on offense if if dak
prescott stays healthy
which he's done every year but last year
it's the defensive part of the equation
that i'm not sure how long that's going
to take but if their goal is to be
average
i mean that seems attainable
ed werder from the mothership covering
the cowboys
more threatening team the chargers of
the rams
given the injuries that have happened
you know cam acres with the rams but who
do you think is more threatening this
year
well i like the rams a lot i covered him
quite a bit last year after
that got hurt the cowboys were out of
contention and and nobody was interested
in them anymore
i really like the the matt stafford
dynamic you know with
uh sean mcvay but the acres injury is
this really significant one in my mind
having watched him and how much you know
he became a dominant factor in the
offense
the second half of the year but i i mean
you got to love the chargers they play
in a tough situation in the division
they're in
hard to imagine them winning the
division over the chiefs
but the young quarterback is fantastic
and we'll see what effect the coaching
change has there
they are a team that can be really good
on defense and on the other side of the
ball so
to answer your question i guess i like
the chargers as a sleeper but i think
the rams probably still have a better
chance of winning their division
cowboys played the steelers in the hall
of fame game uh
your reaction when the steelers decided
to keep ben roethlisberger
a little surprising given his age and
and the sharp decline in his performance
i remember i covered the cowboys game
against the steelers late last year the
steelers were what the last undefeated
team in football i think 11-0
and i i thought it sounded ridiculous i
said this on somebody's radio show
uh i just i i wasn't impressed with the
steelers at that time
you know the emphasis was on getting the
ball out of roethlisberger's hands
quickly
they couldn't protect him they couldn't
run the football um
i'm not entirely surprised i gave him
one more shot given what he's meant to
the organization
and and maybe given that they didn't
think there was a better option out
there in free agency
but i just don't know how well this is
going to turn out for the steelers this
year
yeah i was surprised as well unless they
didn't see a quarterback that they could
get
or that graded out to what they wanted
there but
it and ben wasn't helped out by those
wide receivers
now you bring in harris from alabama you
know
is that running attack gonna help out
ben a little bit more but
uh i was i was curious about that also
the russell wilson story that
exploded of course right after the super
bowl
do you think that the seahawks are
comfortable with russell wilson long
term i think so
but let's see how it plays out this year
i mean
uh he and pete carroll from my
understanding have had a lot of really
good dialogue
uh about the circumstances um
that uh caused russell wilson to
criticize the organization
having watched tom brady go in a super
bowl with everything the bucks did
you know to accommodate him and allow
him to play his best football i mean
at the start of last year we were
talking about what a dominant player
russell wilson was and he was the best
player in the league he was going to win
mvp
um really they failed themselves on the
other side of the ball for the most part
they did become
two one dimensional i mean pete carroll
to me is always going to emphasize
balance and running the football to the
best of his ability so if russell wants
to just go out there and freelance
you know on a consistent basis i don't
know that that's going to be something
pete carroll wants to move to
and i think pete carroll's established
enough as
in that organization and the way they're
structured with john snyder as a general
manager that
you know he could outlast russell wilson
there should
should it come to that i'll leave you
with this the cowboys more likely to
make the nfc title game
or miss the playoffs well they've done
one a lot
more often than they've done the other
uh
so i'm going to say they're a lot more
likely to miss the playoffs just because
they haven't been in a championship game
in 25 years what what would the fallout
be if they don't make the playoffs this
year
i don't know i think it depends on the
circumstances i mean you know
mike mccarthy uh has seen the team he
left go to
consecutive nfc championship games in
his absence
um he's i can tell you his record you
know over the last two years is
is really kind of bad the last two full
seasons he's had
his record in dallas six and ten matched
the fewest games that he won in a full
season over 13 years in green bay
now there were extenuating circumstances
as i mentioned he played 15 different
offensive lines he started four
different quarterbacks so it wasn't
entirely his fault plus
all of the challenges that came with the
pandemic and the limitations in the
off-season
for a first-year head coach that being
said like i said
he made some bad hires he coached some
really bad games
uh i right from the start the rams uh
season opener but the washington game on
thanksgiving day
when they're four points down and he's
running a fake punt you know from
on fourth and 11 from his own into the
field i mean he made barry switzer look
like a game management genius at times
so so so i think that i think mccarthy
to a certain extent is coaching for his
job
if what you we just said is more likely
actually happens if they miss the
playoffs for the third straight year
um depending on how it happens i i could
certainly see
jerry making him the next change which
is the only coach he's ever fired after
two years
has barry switzer ever publicly thanked
jimmy johnson
for giving him gift wrapping and
a super bowl you know barry switzer said
uh to me not too long ago he said look
you don't have to give me credit for
winning a super bowl and for building
you know a super bowl winning team but
at least i didn't screw it up
there are other guys who would have
gotten higher they would have screwed it
up i didn't screw it up so i give him
that much credit at least
play nice today ed we appreciate your
time as always
thanks for the opportunity dad good to
talk to you that's ed werder edwarde has
more
whenever we would do sportscenter it'd
be like and edward has more and then
you'd go to
you'd throw it to edward and then he
would have a story on the cowboy
edwarder
has more